[Applause]
[Music]
Oh what to do
thank you thank you
I realized I didn't have any questioning
what you had no questions for me so you
gave up the seat you know that was a
lovely that was a lovely response you
got when you came out and I gotta tell
you something I've seen you perform live
I saw you with the Largo theater you did
an amazing show but fans go crazy when
they get to see you live that must be a
fun reaction it really is I mean there's
no accounting for taste my mother always
tell me and the the hard part is it's so
it's so wonderful and thank you so much
for your warm response but then it's
daunting because when you start out so
hot then the the onus is on me to to not
drop the ball or [ __ ] the bed as we say
American policy so I so you said you're
feeling this pressure is it because
people know you from this character of
Ron Swanson is that ever a problem it
can be yeah I mean some people are good
at comprehending stories when they hear
them and digest them and they they taken
all the information other people are not
so good at consuming television and so
they can watch a character like Ron
Swanson on Parks and Recreation and
instead of instead of sort of receiving
all the information they cherry pick and
say oh finally a Nazi to represent my
own point of view
so you have some fans that think that
that they just sees a very narrow piece
of what they think is Ron Swanson yeah
there's a small percentage of my fans
you know I love everybody but they see
him as like an old-fashioned misogynist
right wing like gun nut yeah and when
they find out that in truth he's
actually he's a true libertarian he's
open to all people and all creeds and
you know he loves powerful women he says
that again and again then when people
discover that I'm not a misogynist in
real life they get angry that's the
weirdest concept that's really really
you really let me down yeah by not being
the misogynist that I perceived you to
be I apologize and that's why I get
nervous when you cheer at the beginning
I'm like well I'm not gonna slap any
ladies yeah let's just temper our
expectations well I'm the closest thing
to a lady up here so you know speaking
of ladies you have the this as I said
you have this very loyal fan following
and you get this incredible fan art and
we're very lucky here the fans send in
really great interesting drawings and
sculptures sometimes of myself or Andy
and it's just cool to see how creative
they are I know that you're bombarded
with with with art people making art and
your likeness is that right well
something just occurred to me yes you're
right absolutely right and I've seen a
lot of wonderful fan art of you and the
character you play Conan O'Brien on
television now no one could really be
that sexy yeah but this just occurred to
me I get I get so much incredible fan
art mainly Ron Swanson and they have you
your character Conan O'Brien and my
character Ron Swanson both have a pretty
similar hairdo
which in my case we referred to as the
full douche I don't know they call it
around here now we call it the full
douche now that you you've just present
that here's what here's a drawing
someone did I don't know how you feel
about this one
Wow it's eerily good disturbing at the
same time what's good the eyes are
incredible on that by the way it's
really it's really good I get a lot of a
lot of art that seems to be miss shapen
at my outset but then as you settle into
it you realize it's actually quite it's
a photograph that one looks like it was
some kind of therapy yeah yeah or it
looks like a threat of some kind like
someone's like knock it off this so
happened to you it was so good and Megan
saw that it was on social media and she
reply thing was an Instagram thing and
she replied to it and said please help
I've been talking to this for three days
my husband oh yeah someone did this they
put your face on they made you every
character in cats I think we have that
somewhere and
you know what I think I would have gone
and seen that movie had that been what
that cats was you know I mean they I get
that a lot
when it comes to egress elbow especially
especially when they see his work like I
know you should have gone fully fully
gorgeous yeah yeah yeah exactly
Offerman with that guy yeah though that
was pretty upsetting when that catch
thing came out the actual real movie no
the one I didn't I didn't see the the
actual movie are you admitting on TV
that you didn't see the movie cat's eye
I know I must have gotten this wrong I
was under the impression that we weren't
supposed to watch it I got the same
impression and I have not seen it I
don't think anybody here so I did anyone
here to see it you liked it I do think
that you know I'm glad that you spoke up
for it because I I feel like people must
be allowed to like what they like and
that in this time of people shaking
their fists at one another it's okay if
you enjoy something like the live
musical of cats but it was the movie
cats the movie yeah yeah I don't think
that's okay
[Laughter]
does it get it on paper as you could be
right I mean I'm sorry I agree with you
in theory I just think you got to draw a
line somewhere